we are joined here on eight news now by
joe yalda joe is the vice president of
guest
experience for uh station casinos
and uh for the red rock property and joe
i'm
fascinated by your station casinos
experience if we could go back a bit if
you don't mind
you started with station as a busser
at tides oyster bar at the age of 16. is
this all correct
this is very correct yeah it's been such
a blessing the last 15 years
what a history you have as you've moved
up the company
at your first couple of weeks working at
tides oyster bar as a teenager
did you ever think you'd have such
success moving up into the ranks of
executive
you know i would have i would have never
thought it i remember when i first
reached out to get the position i
talked to my high school guidance
counselor he said he's like i'll tell
you what i'll help you get this job he's
like it's probably gonna be the last job
you ever get this company is amazing
and little did i know that turned out to
be true thank god to this day
you got to put that guidance counselor
on your christmas list every year
definitely yeah he gets whatever he
wants how have you seen uh
you're still obviously a young man but
you've been with the company for a
number of years
how have you seen uh stations change
improve as you look back over your own
experience with the company
you know i've seen it evolve from
everything from different restaurant
experiences to different properties to
being able to spend a stint at another
property and come back but
one thing that's always stayed the same
is they've always been a family
environment
and they really treat their team members
like family and with that as the recipe
winning is is uh there's no chance but
to win at that point
your family literally took that uh or
rather took that literally because
i think i'm correct that your sister and
your brother are all a part of the the
family
all part of the tv yep both my brother
and sister are part of the family
that's fantastic what do they do to
create a station casinos
such a family environment i mean it
started 45 years ago with tonight being
our anniversary you know
it was a company built by and for locals
and
with locals being such a crucial part of
this town
it was it was a community thing we
wanted you to come in and feel like you
were at home
it just wasn't another casino or a
dining experience or a gaming experience
we wanted to come and
build relationships i i think anybody
can agree no matter what station casinos
you go to
you have a relationship with one of our
team members there and that's what makes
this company so special in our property
so special to las vegas
let's go back to 1976 you mentioned the
45th anniversary frank fertitta
starting the casino he wanted as you
referenced there he wanted a
local's place why was it so important of
course later becoming bingo palace and
palestinian
why was it so important for a local
place for
for all the las vegas who live here not
tourists they stay here they want a
place to go on a tuesday night to catch
the game
why was that so important to the
fertitta family um i think anybody who's
lived in las vegas for a long time
knows that when you know when you leave
work and mo the chances are you do work
on the strip you don't want to go back
to work
so i think frank furtita junior saw that
opportunity as
a place of like you know what where
would i go when i get off work and what
if i don't want to come back to the
strip
and the casino was born and we're at
where we're at today because of it
it's always fun showing tourists station
casino properties going to green valley
ranch or red rock and they're like
i didn't know this was here this is
awesome it's
cool that's right that's one of the
biggest compliments and i think to top
it more
there's no bigger compliment than when
someone returns
because of the experience they had at
one of our properties
you mentioned in your bio talking about
station casinos the company making you
the best version
of yourself how do they achieve that
goal that seems like quite
a a monumental challenge for a company
to do but clearly doing it
you know the one thing they do that's so
different and talking to people that
work with other companies is they always
consistently provide you an opportunity
i think if you talk to anybody who's
been in the company for multiple years
dave horn the general manager of
palestine is a good example of this
starting as a front desk agent at palace
you know over 20 years ago and now
becoming the general manager
these opportunities present themselves
and if you're a person who takes these
opportunities and runs with them this
company will provide environment for you
to succeed at whatever level you prefer
to
a lot of beautiful success stories like
that somebody starting out
uh maybe a lower kind of role and just
continuing to move up through hard work
that kind of uh moving someone up the
ladder in a company always uh
so appealing to so many when they when
they figure out where they want to work
let's talk about the party we look
behind you we see 45 years
it's time to party fourth of july around
the corner
you guys got everything from fireworks
to parties to different
events planned for different properties
what do you want our viewers to know
about how stations is going to really
celebrate
you know it all starts tonight where it
all started for us 45 years ago so
tonight's fireworks show
is at power station doors open at 7 30
the fireworks go off at nine o'clock and
then on the fourth of july itself we
actually have fireworks at green valley
ranch
and red rock casino um that's open to
the public so if you would like to
attend
you can purchase tickets at any of the
gift shops at red rock or green valley
ranch
prices start at 10 for kids under 12
years old
25 for adults and at red rock 50 for all
you can drink packages
fourth of july fireworks are happening
this weekend but you guys are starting
tonight i love it
it's it's it's a week of fireworks i
can't wait it is really it's so
important to mention this too because i
i've i've had conversations with those
at station casinos and they talk about
this as well
what does this mean for our city not
just for the properties
not just for the business but for our
city to have a local success story
of nearly half a century now it's
it's community it provide it provided
las vegas that sense of community that i
think las vegas needed
um it's everybody you know no matter
what city or what country you come from
you know when you come to a city like
las vegas you end up moving here
you you're almost there's this like
magnetic pull to our properties because
it has such a community outreach
everybody knows somebody that works at
stations
like i said before everybody has a
relationship with everybody and when you
come here you really do feel like you're
at home
and that's something that we've done
that is so different unlike anything
else in the hospitality and gaming
industry
joe what would you tell that 16 year old
version of yourself keep your head down
and keep working
yeah go with the flow and you know
there's going to be challenges along the
way but
uh keep going it's gonna be the best
ride of your life
let's actually go off that point right
there challenges along the way what's
one challenge you've had that you've
been able to transcend and what's been
your favorite part personally
um i've had some personal um family
issues you know my mom was terminally
ill and going through that and
you know eventually her passing but the
company and my team members and my
leadership were there the whole step of
the way
and they really helped my family and i
get through moments like that and
it's it's stories like that that all of
us as team members have that have this
attachment to the company and it's
always there for you it's there for you
when you're you're hitting your lows and
it's there for you on your highs and it
helps you throughout the whole way
that's why we're all forever indebted to
this company that's a really good point
meaningful point because everybody's
going to have their rough road at times
and you want to work for a place that's
going to be kind of
got your back in that challenging time
well said there
uh the party is happening the fertitta
family celebrating what happened back in
1976
what this means to our city as reference
and of course uh
joe and his family continuing to be a
part of station casinos
uh this is great i'm a fan and i know
many of our news now viewers
enjoy a variety of your properties or
they have their own little
local place so joe any parting words
that you'd like to leave our viewers
with
no please come down and check out the
fireworks show
um at the end of the day it's for the
community and happy 45th anniversary to
station casinos and all its amazing team
members that are part of it
well from our eight news now team we
wish you and station casinos a happy
45th and thanks so much for your time
it is appreciated thank you as always
brian have a good rest of your day